hello again I hope I hope that many of
you watched the last video on the
candidates and that you enjoyed it the
host of this particular show is now in
in in Barcelona with his family
my man with your Espen and he was not
available by Skype or I don't I don't
know if he wanted to come on the show
today so now I'm doing it all on my own
so so here goes a lot has happened and
there has been a lot of turn around a
lot of dramatic events but really only
one player has remained stable continued
to play good chess and that's been good
online so last time after six rounds a
nun was living leading my half a point
over a wrong and I Ronin over Turkey in
the next game then he was white against
Thailand quite kind of strange opening
he was lucky not to get worse and made
the draw and then the very next round
Iranian played a very interesting
opening against Musharraf then he
gradually went went astray and unlost
well an unbuilt apollo's since then it's
been it's been all draws for for the two
of them so anonymous leading by one
point and holds the tiebreaker over
after after 12 rounds while Kuryakin is
1/2 points behind that he's playing
we right in the very next round but so
he's really the only guy with a little
bit of a chance but I think the wayanas
playing is pretty confident that he can
hold with black there well my general
impression is that most most of them are
just tiny bit desperate I don't think
you need to go into a street fight to
win to win every game i I read something
Kramnik said about well I'm not Carlson
so I cannot win every equal end game
they don't blender like that against me
well that that might be true but it does
sound some little bit like an excuse but
I anyway I think at some at some point
some of them would be better suited to
to play more like Anand has been playing
in a tournament more pragmatically and
just taking taking worth what's there
and it feels like several of the players
have been trying hard to gain the
initiative then when something goes
wrong they don't defend very well and I
think yeah that's been that's been a
little bit a little bit disappointing
that the level of tenacity
so well we still got to wrap two rounds
to go
as I said Kuryakin has a chance to catch
up with with with Anand he really turned
it around in in the second half I said
last time I believed I didn't believe
that he would turn it round one of the
well as few things I was wrong about
uh-huh and then he will he lost one more
game to two Aronian really a really nice
game by Iranian by the way and then it
looked like it would he was out of it
that he beats fiddler and in a game
where Hitler made some some mistakes and
in the inner arch position that but
corrected also showed some very good
technique by sacrificing the exchange
which was very nice then keep it crumb
neck I think chronics maybe gotten too
much stick for his mistake in the
opening there I don't know exactly what
he missed the idea that he went for with
DC for queen bee 795 maybe to go night
before later on just look that's the
time thing of course included gifts and
quiet advantage immediately but I don't
think it's it's as obvious as people
I've been trying to put it and that then
I think cracking here he had winning
chances against Apollo with black after
tupelov was one of those
didn't didn't really play according to
the demands of the position tenaciously
enough after after he it didn't find a
way to win kind of just drop this level
of play a bit and then but he couldn't
find the way to wind and then also
yesterday I guess Monday off yet
excellent winning chances after he did
defend it very well in serious time
trouble
I think if Kuryakin had won one of those
he would be one point behind and it
could affect it would win the tournament
by beating another tomorrow
now I'm rather more I'm not well I'm not
so optimistic so well overall its but
it's been an exciting tournament quality
it's been a bit up up and down I think
it really shows on in the games of the
players that only the first place counts
but as I said that's that's no reason to
to defend poorly and
so I think think you need to find the
middle ground fund find a balance there
which there's one players managed to do
that so far Anand and that's why I think
he's going he's going to it
so we're I think we're we're done for
now
I'll be well I'm ready to to eat my
words once again if an ant does lose
against career acumen something exciting
happens in the last round but we'll see
so big that's it for now and looking
forward to the last year us